ok grazie a tutti e grazie per avermi
invitato questo evento
buongiorno a tutti a tutte
sono appunto una fotografa
ha trascorso praticamente due terzi
della vita dietro ad una macchina
fotografica e per me questo è un momento
decisamente particolare perché di solito
appunto non sta sempre dietro a dire
alle persone ai miei soggetti quello che
devono fare invece oggi sono qui a
parlare della mia storia e ho iniziato a
lavorare come fotografa molto giovane
come fotografa professionista aveva 21
anni avevo già uno studio dove lavoravo
come fotografa di moda di still life e
realizzando servizi anche di
architettura di arredamento però dopo
dieci anni di questo tipo di attività
dove ho imparato veramente tantissime
cose perché comunque lavorare in studio
è un lavoro veramente molto interessante
usi le luci usi tutti i tipi di macchine
fotografiche che ci sono del mercato nel
mercato in base al soggetto che devi
fotografare per cui ho imparato
veramente molto ma non ero felice c'era
qualcosa dentro di me che non riusciva
non si era mai potuta esprimere e quindi
non ero contenta
mi sentivo mi vergognavo un po anche di
provare questo questo malessere perché
in fondo non mi mancava niente
era una persona realizzata ma niente
c'era questa questa vocina che mi diceva
devi fare qualcos'altro
perché in fondo il mio vero sogno era
quello di
diventare una fotografa di reportage di
reportage di turismo di viaggio ma non
avevo il coraggio di farlo lasciare
insomma non avevo il coraggio di
lasciare lo studio lasciare un porto
sicuro per avventurarmi in un mare che
non conoscevo senza avere una rotta da
seguire
poi però insomma questa voce non
non continuare a farsi sentire quindi ho
deciso un giorno mi sono sentita pronta
per così dire per affrontare il rischio
perché comunque nella vita bisogna fare
delle scelte
se si vuole raggiungere qualche cosa e
bisogna anche esporsi al rischio di
quello che la scelta comporta quindi un
giorno a milano mi sono presentata
all'ufficio norvegese per il turismo con
un portfolio di immagini di viaggi che
avevo fatto appunto in norvegia e ho
suonato il campanello alle 17 25 quando
l'ufficio sapevo che avrebbe chiuso alle
17 e 30 quindi ero veramente titubante
nel fare questa cosa però alla fine
questo gesto questo gesto coraggioso ha
avuto ha prodotto degli ottimi frutti
ho iniziato proprio con l'ente norvegese
a lavorare nel settore del turismo
dopodiché con l'ente danese e poi con
l'ente svedese poi con le linee aeree
scandinave ho fatto insomma tantissimi
lavori con coloro questa sono io in
antartide qualche paio 23 anni fa
inviata per la rivista dove adesso
dunque vorrei vedere ok questa invece
sono le foto delle isole lofoten in
norvegia sono le immagini che ho
presentato all'ente norvegese quando mi
sono presentata proprio per iniziare una
collaborazione con loro
avevo realizzato un lavoro sulla pesca
del merluzzo alle isole lofoten oltre il
circolo polare artico e norvegia
l'importante quando si realizzano delle
foto quando si realizza un servizio è
non fare delle foto così a casaccio di
paesaggi perché queste non interessano a
nessuno
una persona può arrivare lì fare trovare
una luce stupenda un'inquadratura
meravigliosa fa una foto bella ma alla
fine è una sola foto
quello che bisogna fare quando si lavora
con una rivista o quando si prepara un
portfolio è organizzare un vero e
proprio servizio fotografico un
reportage proprio e quindi c'era adesso
qui ce ne sono veramente poche comunque
ops per andare avanti perdonatevi allora
quindi per raccontare la pesca del
merluzzo le isole le foto lofoten nel
mese di marzo
di conseguenza avevo l'immagine del
paesaggio l'immagine dei pescatori
l'immagine dei merluzzi stesi ad
essiccare e poi ovviamente il piatto il
piatto con con il merluzzo quindi ecco
queste sono alcune delle immagini con
cui mi sono presentata da lì comunque
avendo tutte le esperienze dei dieci
anni di lavoro e studio le persone hanno
capito comunque che dietro dietro di me
c'era un ottimo spessore e quindi poi ho
iniziato a lavorare appunto con la
danimarca e questo è copenaghen con
con la svezia la finlandia questa è la e
questa appunto un immagine nella
lapponia svedese perché in quei
territori sono diventata una vera e
propria esperta del dei territori
scandinavi perché a me piace molto
approfondire
non mi piace andare in un posto mettere
la bandierina e dire sono stata qui sono
stata lì
questo lo trovo veramente il poco
interessante mentre trovo veramente
interessante approfondire e appunto
lavorato tantissimo e scandinavia
mi sono anche confrontata con quella
cultura che ai tempi vi parlo di 25 anni
fa era veramente molto diversa rispetto
alla cultura italiana loro ad esempio
hanno una tradizione del del green della
tutela dell'ambiente che storica proprio
mentre da noi è una cosa diciamo che è
cominciata da poco mi sono anche
confrontata con uno stile fotografico
completamente diverso da quello italiano
e quindi è a me piaceva tantissimo lo
proprio assorbito l'ho fatto mio e
quindi questo è anche il bello del
viaggiare non bisogna mai pensare di
essere i migliori ma bisogna sempre
essere aperti per
confrontarsi proprio per integrare
quello che quello che si quello che si
vede quello che si apprende viaggiando e
quindi migliorare penso che appunto il
viaggio il conoscere tanta gente il
dover fare comunque un servizio
fotografico e dover fotografare persone
ristoranti hotel artisti
ecco è un viaggio dove si conoscono
tantissime persone non è un viaggio dove
si guardano soltanto paesaggi panorami
poi ovviamente comunque il mio lavoro è
proseguito è proseguito ho lavorato in
tutto il mondo qui sono sull'isola di
tasmania non sono quello che è uno più
passa sta fotografando all isola di
tasmania in australia
e qui invece sono in canada
all nel quebec a lily della mad men dove
appunto per soli 15 giorni all'anno cioè
la possibilità di salire sul pack e
fotografare
il fotografare e piccoli di foca che
vengono al mondo sono viaggi veramente
molto interessanti perché ci si rende
conto di quanto sottile sia il nostro di
quanto sia sottile l'ecosistema ecco in
cui viviamo
perché la vita di queste delle forze ad
esempio della marlane dipende proprio
dallo spessore del ghiaccio
se il ghiaccio non si forma finisce la
vita ecco e qui invece siamo in val
grande e questa è stata una foto di
apertura di un servizio pubblicato poco
tempo fa dalla rivista dove è
ecco ultimamente sto lavorando molto
anche nel verbano cusio ossola e mi
piace proprio per questo perché mi piace
approfondire
mi piace lavorare anche vicino a casa
per cui non ho velleità di andare chissà
dove sono contenta dei viaggi che ho
fatto
però
però mi piace soprattutto approfondire e
conoscere la gente perché quando si
vedono per tante volte gli stessi
paesaggi nelle varie stagioni si
incontrano tante volte le persone quando
si conoscono le persone del territorio
allora si riesce veramente a tirare
fuori qualcosa di particolare che
altrimenti andando in un posto
trascorrendo 15 minuti veramente non si
riesce a tirare fuori niente di
particolare quindi appunto questo è il
questo è il sono alcune immagini che ho
scattato ecco questo va bene la parete
est del questa è l'ultima immagine se
non sbaglio e la parete est del monte
rosa con un con un parapendio
ecco è quindi quello che vorrei dire è
che nella mia vita comunque ho dato
retta a quella vocina che mi diceva che
dovevo fare qualcos'altro che la mia
attività non era diciamo quella dello
studio ma dovevo produrre delle immagini
relativi ai territori per la promozione
dei territori per la promozione
turistica dei territori per dovevo
lavorare nel settore dell'ospitalità
dovevo lavorare con la gente
dovevo affrontare anche i problemi meteo
perché a volte appunto piove e quindi
queste cose sono cose che mi stimolano
mi mettono insomma adrenalina e mi
piacciono rispetto al lavoro dello
studio che bene o male sempre standard
su piatti le luci arriva una splendida
modella uno splendido modello e le cose
sono sempre tutte perfette mentre nella
realtà di tutti i giorni le cose non lo
sono e quindi devi trovare continuamente
delle soluzioni ed è un mestiere molto
stimolante poi un'altra cosa che vorrei
dire che in questi 40 anni di attività
non mi sono mai assolutamente annoiata
per cui penso veramente che questo sia
che questo sia proprio il mestiere della
vita ho trovato per così dire la mia
strada e poi è stato anche divertente
perché la fotografia in 40 anni è
cambiata tantissimo quindi negli ultimi
anni da quando è nato il digitale noi
fotografi siamo dovuti comunque tornare
dietro ai banchi di scuola per imparare
a utilizzare il digitale è inoltre
smartphone digital e social hanno
cambiato completamente il mondo della
fotografia
adesso siamo veramente bombardati di
immagini e direi anche troppo c'è di
tutto c'è l'immagine del professionista
dell'amatore dello pista e si fa un po
fatica a mio parere a sostenere tutto
questo peso quindi adesso fotografare
per un fotografo professionista visto
che è diventato così facile fare delle
fotografie è diventato ancora più più
difficile il mestiere
quindi non è soltanto una questione di
attrezzatura di luci bisogna avere delle
idee bisogna avere fantasia e e poi
coinvolgere anche le persone per
realizzare quello che si ha in testa
perché continuamente fare continuamente
immagini di paesaggi insomma dopo un po
i nostri può proprio più e quindi
bisogna cercare un proprio stile ed è
questo appunto che spingerei
spingerà insomma le persone spingerei
voi gli appassionati di fotografia
gli appassionati di ogni lavoro a
trovare insomma delle proprie strategie
delle delle proprie idee originali per
in qualche modo essere produrre qualcosa
di diverso da quello che c'è già sul
mercato per essere diversi e quindi e
quindi questo è il mio augurio che
faccio a tutti voi
[Applauso]